good evening everyone I'm Laura Ingram
in Washington let's get right to the
angle let me tell you what we're not
going to get used to in the United
States as the new normal or dismiss as a
one-off or just another senseless act of
violence when a jihadist games our
immigration system gets a green card
rents a truck and in the name of Allah
Mo's down innocence in a major American
city that is not nor will it ever be
acceptable in the u.s. protect
particularly when it's preventable as
this act of terror may have been like
clockwork the platitudes are flying from
city officials is an international
symbol of freedom and democracy that's
what we are and we are proud of it that
also makes us a target for those people
who oppose those concepts of course New
York is susceptible to attack duh every
city is susceptible to attack those
words mean nothing we want action from
elected officials to keep this country
in cities like New York safe and
listening to this makes me think of the
mass Islamic resettlement in Europe we
saw terror attacks in Barcelona Paris
London Manchester on and on now do you
remember what we heard from polish Prime
Minister bata Xylo last summer after the
truck attack in Manchester England
she said the following do we want
politicians who claim we have to get
used to attacks or who describe
terrorists attacks as incidents or do we
want strong politicians who can see the
danger and fight against it efficiently
I know one politician who saw the danger
back in August of 2016 in Youngstown
Ohio candidate Donald Trump had this to
say about radical Islam nor can we let
the hateful ideology of radical Islam
its oppression of women
gays children and non-believers be
allowed to reside or spread within our
own countries we must use ideological
warfare as well very important and they
use it on us better than we have ever
even thought of using it on them but
that will change just as we won thank
you
just as we won the Cold War in part by
exposing the evils of communism and the
virtues of free markets so too must we
take on the ideology of radical Islam
after he was elected president Trump
issued an executive order to temporarily
halt travel from countries of concern
and crack down on illegal immigration
for that he was branded as cruel and
heartless
you know what's cruel and heartless
bikers and pedestrians run over in broad
daylight in a major American city that's
cruel and heartless Trump's instincts
about what it takes to secure the
homeland are correct protect our borders
deport lawbreakers build the wall halt
refugees from certain countries given
the severity of the threat these are
common-sense solutions so far here's
what we know the slime that took eight
lives today is a radicalized booze Beck
he got a green card through the
diversity visa program according to my
sources
you know what Donald Trump proposed in
his immigration reform priorities to
Congress a few weeks ago the president
expressly asked for the elimination of
the diversity visa program that grants
50,000 green cards annually at random
through a lottery it's a total scam
tonight I'm also thinking of those
activists lower court judges like those
too Obama appointees who just weeks ago
ruled against the president's travel
bans calling them anti-muslim those
Becca Stan was not on the list it should
be I'd love to ask judges Derek Watson
and Theodore Shuang is it now time to
restrict who comes into
country shouldn't we now make sure that
all visitors or US visa holders are not
a threat to our citizens throughout the
campaign
president Trump warned about the refugee
flow into the United States which is why
so many were shocked this month when he
agreed to permit 45,000 refugees into
the country
we're apparently doing extreme venting
on them
I asked general Kelly exactly what that
meant last night okay and how we extreme
that it what's what is extreme vetting a
vetting is we simply interview people
and have to satisfy ourselves that the
person we're talking to is indeed the
person so they won't come in that maybe
you can't really verify that if we can't
verify I don't think we should let them
into the country president Trump was
elected in part in large part because
voters appreciated his no-nonsense
pragmatism on issues like homeland
security and immigration although we
can't stop all terror attacks in the
United States the safety of the American
people demand that we do what we can to
stop those attacks that are preventable
9/11 should have made it obvious to
everyone that Islam has a hideous
radicalization problem Donald Trump put
the onus on Muslim leaders on his first
foreign trip to get their houses in
order and reform from within here at
home we should not lose one more
American life because politicians don't
have the nerve or the will to do what's
necessary to secure the homeland our
safety is their primary responsibility
and that's the angle